star chef Christian Kruger is a hundred
percent focused it's the toughest
competition he's ever entered 24
candidates are competing in the Bocuse
d'Or in Lyon France all of them among
their country's top chefs each team has
exactly 5 hours and 35 minutes to
prepare one fish and one meat dish trout
and chicken were decided on well in
advance and fennel was added as an
obligatory vegetable the day before the
contest points are awarded for taste
presentation and technique we're aiming
for a place among the top 10 than that
would be great back home in Mannheim
Christian Krueger's team spent a year
and a half practicing in a kitchen just
like the one in the contest
the coaching team is also made up of
star chefs
in the last session they fine-tune the
workflows and timing
at first it took them 12 hours for the
two dishes now they can do it in half
that time they can practice to
perfection but if the contest anything
can happen you might cut yourself and
get disqualified or you get nervous
you've got three or four thousand people
watching you fish and vegetables rolled
up in balls it's complicated but the
presentation is a prime factor for the
jury after all dining is an experience
14 plates have to be served Patrick
Harris observes the dress rehearsal
later he'll be Germany's jury member in
Lyon as events he is a podium shot for
if you make it into the top three you've
earned a night owned among chefs as soon
as they step off the podium they've got
five or six headhunters waiting with
prime contracts winning year is a
worldwide accreditation for top
gastronomy the topic a salami bed fight
for the chicken dish the team gets
innovative
for the side dish Christian Krueger
modes chicken feet out of cream of
vegetable there are countries whose
candidates took a year to have off they
work in advance so they've done nothing
but practice with a book whose door
every day we have to work and earn a
living the German team has invested some
200 thousand euros in their effort some
other candidates have put a million
euros on it the practice conditions vary
but everyone has a chance the decisive
factor is taste if you want to win you
have to be original you have to prove
you can master the techniques and that
you work very clearly and hygienic
almost four hours later everything is
going as planned the German teams fans
have come all the way from Mannheim was
a wonderful audience a great atmosphere
everything's going fine the team
practiced the meat dish over and over
again they hope to earn points in Leo
with extravagance the chicken meat is
hidden inside an egg with the shell of
baked mushrooms
the fans are even allowed to have a
taste as hakuna this foot I'm amazed to
me it's heaven on earth but it's the
jury's opinion that counts genuine works
of art are served up at 10-minute
intervals the jury samples the dishes
and judges taste texture and appearance
that evening the winner is announced
Norway it's the fifth time they've won
only France has done better
the Germans are bitterly disappointed
the 11th place isn't exactly the best
place 1st place would have been the best
place
the Bocuse d'Or a topical aide in the
world of gourmet cuisine